die lage ist super heute morgen war es
noch die stabile seitenlage
so lernten am morgen aufgestanden bin
okay lage ich konnte mich in keine
richtung mitdrehen war wie im gefängnis
aber ihr problemlagen super jetzt alles
entspannt du bist waren sich auch in der
presse moment und zwar nicht weil die
zeitung deinen seine neue platte feiern
sondern wegen einer geschichte du hast
das video anhörung in einem gericht hier
in nordrhein westfalen gedreht und die
wussten irgendwie nicht bescheid haben
das video jetzt gesehen und jetzt gibt
es riesen ärger oder ist es riesenärger
ist es kein riesen ärger laut der presse
ist es ein skandal
aber wenn man mich fragt ist es halt
dieses überspitzte überspitzte die
überspitzte berichterstattung dieser
boulevardpresse halt ich meine das sind
ja auch so die medien die dafür bekannt
sind sachen die wirklich so überspitzt
darzustellen sollen die das machen wenn
die dadurch ihre auflage besser verkauft
bekommen
ok aber was du schon machst ich sag mal
du der song besteht daraus dass du
erklärt warum du dieses gericht nicht
anerkennt und am ende kommen maskierte
mit waffen rein und es wird abgeblendet
und letztlich wenn man es auch im
zusammenhang mit dem nächsten video
sieht wurde aus dem gericht mit diesen
leuten rauskommst noch mal die
schlagzeile übrigens selber auch in der
hand hast entsteht der eindruck du hast
ja umbringen lassen was überhaupt keinen
respekt vor gerichten ist das so willst
du dass damit aussagen ist es bei dir
persönlich so oder was willst du damit
bezwecken natürlich gewisse ich habe
einen gewissen grund respekt gegenüber
jedem menschen und ich bin auch jetzt
kein
salafist oder sowas der jetzt keine
ahnung auf das gesetz heißt und seien
komplett seinen eigenen weg geht ich
respektiere das schon
nur ich sage nur gott kann geschichten
und wenn ich diesen satz nicht sagen
würde dann wäre ich einfach ich würde
mich selbst verleugnen und das tue ich
einfach nicht ich finde das gesetz und
der glaube ich rede jetzt speziell von
der glaube nicht mein glaube weil auch
dein glaube und der glaube vom
kameramann oder was weiß ich dass wenn
man wenn man nach dem glauben lebt dann
denke ich kommt man mit dem gesetz in
konflikt weil der glaube ja sowieso
einen dazu animiert indirekt ein
besserer mensch zu sein und deswegen
auch die letzte zeile und es geht jetzt
im video auch nicht darum dass sich das
dass ich diese ganze szenario nicht
akzeptiere oder diesem gericht nicht
akzeptieren sondern dieses lied ist
komplett einfach nur ein meinungsmacher
es ist der zweite song von meinem album
und ich wollte einfach so viel von mir
erzählen wie ich es im vorfeld noch nie
getan habe und deswegen habe ich einfach
diese meinungsmacher gemacht ich werde
mit verschiedenen fragen einfach
konfrontiert wie stehst du zu
frauenfeindlichkeit wie stehst du zu wie
stehst du zu homosexuellen menschen
warum hast du in der vergangenheit das
gemacht warum dies einfach diese fragen
habe ich anhand von einem song einfach
beantwortet und ich finde der song hat
nur positives ich verstehe die letzte
zeile dass sie so ein bisschen komisch
aufgefasst werden von gewissen menschen
verstehe ich total
aber der song ist etwas total positives
ich sage das so schöne sachen drin
zum beispiel ich habe sie nicht ganz
feststellen kann hätte ich gesagt okay
wenn ich sage
äußern sie sich zu der
frauenfeindlichkeit
ich bin dominant aber frauenfeindlich
nein und wenn ich sage ich sage ja ich
bin dominant aber frauenfeld nicht nein
dann ist auf einmal die schlagzeile in
einer bild zeitschrift frauenfeindlicher
rapper mit mit mit welchem gesicht mit
wie kann man sich denn nach so einer
zelle zu äußern dass ich dann
frauenfeindlich bin oder wenn ich sage
nichts ist so groß wie der respekt vor
meiner mama ihr wort ist mein gesetz ihr
lächeln ist mein sieg ihr leben heißt
frieden ihre tränen heißen krieg das
sind so zeilen wenn ich diese zellen von
toten hosen hören würde oder wenn ich
die zeilen von einem herbert grönemeyer
oder von die ärzte oder was weiß ich was
hören würde
ich würde gern so bekommen wir denken
wow was für eine coole zeile respekt
dafür aber nach diesen zellen scheine
ich wohl frauenfeindlich zu sein und das
ist nicht die einzigste textpassage die
meiner meinung nach positiv ist ich
erkläre den leuten von meiner
vergangenheit dass ich auch scheiße
gebaut habe aber ich sage das ist nicht
schön so mit dem jetzt weiß ich als mein
vater zum thema hinter mit dem alter
kommt die reife und einfach nur ein sehr
positiver song der dann aber in den
medien so negativ dargestellt wird
das geht nicht
findest du dich den missverstanden also
ich finde es kommt schon als ich sag mal
was über deine mutter sachs ist positiv
aber nicht alles ich sag mal du findest
ja nicht alle frauen toll wenn ich das
mal so zusammenfassen darf finde ich
denn nicht nur der frauen die nicht
deinem rollenverständnis entsprechen die
vielleicht mit schon dem einen oder
andern mann im bett war dass das habe
ich noch nirgendwo größer
ich hab's doch nun kommt das ist
vielleicht nein das genau davon erzähle
ich doch die ganzen erlassen die
vorurteile
du hast du hast jetzt gerade dieses
vorurteil das ist so ein mensch bin der
am besten jungfrau haben will
er ist das so also was dahinter kommt so
rüber
das ist aber ein vorurteil genauso wie
der sind würdest du wirklich ehrlich
sagen es ist ein vorurteil also du
würdest definierte er definitiv
ich habe auch schon mal eine längere
beziehung geführt wo die frau ihre
vergangenheit hatte er solche frauen
sind für dich nicht sofort [ __ ]
nein nein auf gar keinen fall aber was
diese rollenverteilung angeht
ich respektiere das ich habe nichts
dagegen wenn jetzt hier eine frau ist
die sogar macht weiß ich was gemacht hat
mir ist scheißegal jeder soll machen wie
er pokert
ich sage nur was meine meinung ist wie
ich es gerne hätte
wenn ich sage ihm in meiner welt muss
nicht die frau zu hause sitzen weil das
ist das was war was diese der vorurteil
ist der vorteil ist dass die frau mit
kopftuch zu hause verschleiert sitzen
soll
und ich bin draußen partymachen [ __ ]
kippeln purzeln und ich kann alles
machen
so ist es nicht zwar nichts ergeben gibt
es auch es gibt überall bescherte
menschen nicht nur
nicht nur in unserem glauben auch in
anderen glaubensrichtungen
ich bin aber nicht so ich sage einfach
nur das ist meine sicht der sache und
worauf wartet jetzt nochmal hinaus jeder
soll machen wir bock hat ich respektiere
das aber wie gesagt der songs der
meinungsmache ist wird um meine
ansichten nicht schwul zu sein ich mich
auch nicht wenn jetzt hier zwei
homosexuelle menschen sitzen würden rum
lecken werden
mir wäre das total egal sollen wir
machen aber es ist nicht mein ding ich
brett prebble des 120 die scheide und
das ist mein außerdem gehe ich auch
stehe und ich musste eine strecke
aufstehen und mit lecken er ist einfach
nicht mein ding sondern die aber machen
bis heute ist nicht mehr stören trotzdem
ist der song er auch wenn du jetzt sagst
ich nehme das nur als ich sag mal
möglichkeit und er habe diese szenerie
genommen um darzustellen wo ich stehe
und aber viele ähnliche sachen gesagt
trotzdem konnte kommt der konfrontativ
rüberkommt konfrontativ rüber gegenüber
schwulen weil du eben ganz deutlich
macht auf das ist nichts für mich
erklärt schon deine distanz und das
kommt auch gegenüber dem gericht herüber
also es kommt nicht rüber
ich bin so brav und deswegen kann mir
ein gericht nicht sondern es ist kommt
rüber als ihr könnt mich mal alle
kreuzweise weil ich verantworte mich nur
gegenüber gott ich sagte so wenn ich
wenn ich was gegen schwule hätte dann
würde ich sagen weil ich mache kein pop
ich mache kein rockig mal ich verliere
keine käufer im hip hop ist in die
meisten leute die hip hop hören sind
sowieso da ist das sowieso nicht
verkannt aber es ist nicht üblich so ich
würde dadurch keine hörer verlieren
sagen wir es mal so wenn ich jetzt sagen
würde er ich mag schwule nicht aber es
ist nicht so
es ist nicht so dass ich schwule nicht
mag nächstes egal so lieber machen wer
bock ich bin aber nicht so es geht darum
es geht um meine ansichten im song
anhörung und nicht um seine um ihre das
so wie ich denke aber trotzdem langsam
zum gericht warum lässt es wirkt also
jeder der diese dinge gesehen hat denkt
du hälst nichts von deutschen gerichten
das ist kommt einfach super deutlich
rüber weil ich sage nur gott kann mich
richten sich leute im anschluss kostet
häufig stopp am schluss kommen bewaffnet
leute rein oder aber das ist doch guck
mal reden wir jetzt vom sommer reden wir
vom video wir reden vom gesamtkunstwerk
dass das ist das sind zwei komplett
verschiedene paar schuhe
das sind zwar kommunal die hängen ja
schon zusammen wenn ich das eine wenn
ich jetzt sehe ich kenne wie muss ich
kenne videos wo die wo das szenario vom
video nichts mit dem song zu tun hat gar
nichts weil dies ist aber nicht der fall
das szenario songs schon ein wenig des
videos schon ein wenig mit dem song so
gut es geht also guck mal ist mir schon
klar dass das das ist jetzt nicht also
ich werde jetzt nicht morgen wirklich
vor gericht hin und dann wirklich allen
ernstes glauben dass ich von 34 kollegen
befreit werden kann
dass das würde sich auch nicht gehören
darum geht es nicht aber es ist einfach
einen action-streifen was das visuelle
angeht also der song ich stehe hinter
jeder zeile vom song aber dass videos
einfach eine idee von der
produktionsfirma gewesen okay lass uns
was so darstellen so das wird cool was
wird vielleicht sogar ein bisschen
brisant verschießt wie ich meine ich
weiß ja auch wie ich mit diesen ganzen
brisanten themen und provokationen
umzugehen habe und das ist einfach ein
action streifen ich habe schon mal
irgend einem anderen interview habe ich
das schon mal erwähnt aber wenn bruce
willis oder wenn bernd eichinger so
einen film dreht oder irgendjemand den
action streifen dreht dann ist es auch
dann redet keiner drüber aber bei mir
ist ein skandal
warum denn nur empfehlen ist es nicht
ein skandal nein warum was hat denn
dieses was hat denn dieser action
streifen mit der politik zu tun und wenn
es so wäre
arnold schwarzenegger gouverneur nächste
große action held aus amerika den es
jemals gab neben anderen ich will noch
mal von der anderen seite aufgreifen
canucks in paris das ist ein klarer
action streifen das ist das ist überhöht
das ist traumatisiert aber du sagst ja
selber dein song anhörung da geht es dir
um über dich persönlich geht es ja darum
über dich persönlich was zu erzählen und
das wird dann mit etwas bebildert wo du
sagst es ist ein action streifen das ist
kunst ja aber kannst du nicht
nachvollziehen dass die leute dann
ausflippen und sagen der kommt da so
wahrhaftig vor der kamera über dann
verbindet er mit es mit sowas ist das
nicht auch wahrhaftig ich kann es
nachvollziehen
also ich kann die ganze aufregung um
dieses wiederum nachvollziehen
auch spekuliert überhaupt nicht also wir
haben uns schon gedacht okay das könnte
leicht brisant ankommen die idee stand
auch
gar nicht am anfang so ich hätte auch
ganz anders machen können hätte ich
hätte auch nicht anrufen können und
sagen können
christoph hast du nicht mit mir video zu
drehen wir machen das im rahmen eines
interviews du bist der journalist und du
fragst mich äußern sie sich schritte zu
der frauenfeindlichkeit
es hätte auch rtl richter sein müssen es
hätte auch 1 1 ein klassenzimmer sein
können oder was weiß ich
aber wir haben uns einfach gedacht das
passt am besten es ist brisant warum
nicht machen wir das das auge isst mit
wir wollen cooles video drehen schwert
befreit die aufregung aber dass das so
groß wird in den medien
damit hätte keiner gerechnet aber es ist
mir wirklich egal mir scheißegal
mir ist egal wer was darüber denkt ich
mache sowieso mein ding schon haben
schon immer gemacht hat mir von
niemanden was sagen lassen
mach dass du nicht oder macht macht das
auf diese art nicht ist mir kg ist die
zu 100 hinter dem song und der song ist
einfach ein meinungsmacher wie gesagt
und das video ist ein action streifen 40
dann immer anders gefragt wir kommen
immer wieder oder mit ganz vielen von
aus der der hip hop region kommen wir
immer wieder aufs thema was ist etwas
unterhaltung und was ist echt und
besteht nicht die gefahr mit wenn ich
das als unterhaltung verkaufe dass ich
nicht doch ein
ich sag mal die ältere generation würde
sagen die junge junge generation
verführer dass du leuten als vorbild
gilt die dann sagen ja stimmt ich werde
von gott gerichtet und wenn ich sage
auch ich kann den abstrichen dann ist
das ok und das wird am ende entscheiden
da hamburg
da haben wir dein vorurteil jedem eine
befürchtung dass das passiere vor ende
warum es dass deine fischen jeder denn
jeder der jetzt ich gehe sogar schritt
weiter jeder der was gegen dieses video
hat hat einfach vorurteile
nein warum ich erkläre warum weil du
sagst abstechen
wo steht denn in deinem glauben dass
jemand abstrichen sitzt jemand der
glaubt wird das nicht tun aber jemand
der ich sag mal vorgibt zu glauben und
trotzdem seinen dingen einfach schlecht
menschen gibt es überall christopher
aber ein nutzen diese schlechten
menschen dann nicht oder besteht nicht
die gefahr dass die dein video als
rechtfertigung also wenn mein held der
casey das sagt dann kann ich ja machen
ich bin so froh also dass es menschen
gibt die mich ich sage niemandem nimmt
mich als beispiel das mache ich nicht
ich bin ich bin mir meiner aber ich bin
mir trotzdem meine verantwortung bewusst
und die leute die mich als beispiel
nehmen
sie liegen immer noch besser damit
vivendi irgendeinen anderen rapper als
beispiel nehmen
warum weil bei mir wird klar was ehrlich
gemeint ist was nicht in diesen in
diesem trotz gerade das video auf mich
gekommen bin das neueste ja da merkst du
sofort mein gesicht ist angemalt und was
die treppe sind ganz klar kohl genau
weiß jeder aber in songs wie anhörung
merkst du auch okay das ist jetzt gerade
die was das ist das ist gerade das ist
gerade er gibt was von seinem leben
preis und aber alles positiv ich hätte
mir gewünscht dass du den song
vielleicht vorbereitet hat ist dass wir
die zeilen durchgehen können
ich will sehen was du was du passt ihr
nicht gefällt und welche zeile ich kann
mir zwei sachen vorstellen und die sage
ich von mir aus
sonst gibt es
wo ich sage meiner existenz diese diese
stelle zum beispiel ja aber ich bin auch
nur ein mensch
das sogar das wird und ich hab' ich habe
manchmal diesel ohne dass die sage weißt
du was meine existenz ich hasse die ich
mag die nicht damit bin ich nicht
frauenfeindlich warum nicht so
vielleicht habe ich auch schon ein
kleiner um bist du nicht frauenfeindlich
wenn du sagst meine ex ist eine
fahrtzeit hier aber warum soll warum
soll man warum soll man frauen besser
oder schlechter behandeln sie sind doch
gleich oder nicht und ich genau richtig
genau wie ich sage genau so wie ich sage
meiner existenz kann ich auch sagen ich
habe die ganze auf seinen kollegen
vertraut der sich bereits vor und
dargestellt bin ich dann jetzt
schwulenfeindlich oder bin ich immer
offen und menschenfeindlichkeit suchen
soll
nein das sind überall so das ist das ist
überspitzt
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir uns
hier im rat befinden und dass eine
gewisse fäkalsprache nicht okay ist aber
es ist kein tabu das heißt leute die rap
hören die die sind die vielen sich nicht
auf den fuß getreten werden wir auf
einmal ein wort scheiße hören oder die
trotz oder gerade auch meine hörerschaft
nicht meine hörerschaft kann einiges
hören wobei ich nicht nur solche musik
mache ich mache auch liebeslieder
ich mache auch ich mache auch kennst du
mein song rot blaues licht
kennst du nicht nein ok guck mal ich
sagte jetzt die huk zeile von rot blaues
licht da sage ich schütze deine kinder
vor dem licht deine tochter vor dem
rotlicht dein sohn vor dem blaulicht
dass das ist das ist die huk mit dieser
hub mit diesem song und mit diesem video
habe ich es nicht in einem bild zeitung
geschafft ich habe es nicht
in nach ich war nicht der erste
präsident nicht uns nicht im zdf um die
ganzen medien wo ich in den letzten
tagen und wochen auf einmal zu sehen bin
diese leute wollen wollen menschen wie
mich die brauchen menschen wie mich und
da dass diese sätze raus zu ziehen und
diese schlagzeilen raus zu ziehen um die
den leuten so zu verkaufen die sie haben
wollen
ja wobei du bist also ich sage mal so
jedem produzenten der dieses video
gedreht hätte dem ist wäre absolut
bewusst gewesen dass er hier eine grenze
überschreitet in einem bericht zu drehen
hier da hätte das getreten mehr
jeder produzent jeder videoproduzenten
das getreten das war wirklich nicht
abzusehen wir haben eine drehgenehmigung
sie wussten die wussten ja von allem
bescheid wussten sie dass am schluss von
maskierte täter waffen ins gericht
kommen und natürlich natürlich christoph
der zwölf stunden gedreht
die sind diese die die szenen wie die
vom auto angekommen sind ausgestiegen
sind und die treppen hoch gelaufen sind
vielleicht war mit dabei
zwölf stunden dauert das mal seine
rechnung das war einem normalen
wochentag oder anderen samstag
nein da war betrieb von morgens bis okay
wir waren ungefähr so gegen 20 uhr war
da keiner mehr
okay wir wollen noch dann hat er die
szene mitmachen wir haben diesen ganz
ganz
wir haben die in der früh gedreht als
wir direkt gekommen sind dies wegen das
heißt sie hätten das mitbekommen können
und müssen
nein die haben sie nicht bekommen haben
ist mit natürlich haben sie das
mitbekommen haben genehmigungen ja das
heißt nicht auch du sagst lobby waren
haben einfach die augen zugemacht oder
war blöd oder gab es nicht die folgen
ich weiß nicht ob du das gelesen hast
die bild oder sollte beschrieben
da gab es sogar eine frau die total
eingeschüchtert war weil die auf einmal
diese masken leute gesehen hat etwas
mitbekommen ok die war ja auch vom links
die wahl auch vom land gerät
sie hat sich ja mitbekommen aber sie war
eine der personen die es nicht wussten
das wusste in china die beauftragten die
leute die dafür zuständig sind die
wussten was uns aber da ist doch nichts
passiert
das heißt die die jetzt sagen wie
schlimm ich habe von nichts gewusst
die wussten doch einfach mal wissen
müssen die wissen alle die wissen was
aber die müssen was doch jetzt sagen die
oder meinte diesem zerrbild gegangen und
haben gesagt ey wir wussten das nicht
nein bild irgendwann zu dem gemacht so
und dann natürlich ich sage ich dass die
lügen aber die schmieden sich die
antworten natürlich auch wo wie die am
besten dastehen würde mir natürlich
schon ruf zu verlieren aber ich finde
die hätten einfach dazu stehen sozusagen
so okay wir wussten es nicht ganz genau
bescheid aber es ist halt musikvideo
damit wären sie besser vom schneider
vivendi jetzt einfach so total
unbeholfen die ganze zeit folgend da
kann man nicht wissen was sie sagen
sollte und was ich gehört habe am
drehort war sie die darsteller der
polizisten waren polizisten
also die richter waren schauspieler und
die polizistin
waren polizisten also weil man darf gar
keine polizisten spielen in deutschland
sondern es müssen polizisten seien wir
mal uniformen haben will
das weiß ich habe mich damit leider
nicht also noch nie so richtig
auseinandergesetzt wäre was spielen darf
aber ich weiß dass die richter gespielt
waren und die polizisten echt worden und
da gab es keine proteste gegen das was
da gespielt wurde und bisschen
schauspieler
wir haben ja einen action-streifen klar
aber von anderer seite der ganze ort ist
man kann es nicht jedem recht machen
ich meine künstlerische meinungsfreiheit
in deutschland und wie leben wir nach
dem gesetz guter spruch zum luft- oder
nicht vielen dank